(chuckles)
- I watch the Oscars because
of the fabulous dresses.
(audience applauds)
- I watch the Oscars to see
what shoes everyone is wearing
and who shows up.
- I'm always interested to see
what people are gonna
wear on the red carpet.
- It is such an incredible thrill
when you see people glammed
up, having such a good time.
- I watch the Oscars
because it's the Super
Bowl for film nerds.
(men chuckle)
- I see it more as the
Super Bowl of culture.
- Oh, I like it.
- People are sweating,
and they're like nervous.
It feels like real life.
- Every year, I see my friends,
we come together and
watch the Oscars together,
and this is really fun.
- I'm obsessed with watching the Oscars,
and I do it every year.
And I live in Britain,
so I stay up all night.
I can't miss it, and I love it. (laughs)
- They're the coolest show ever.
And now, I get to be a part of them,
which even makes it cooler for me.
- It’s such a celebration
for all we accomplish on a daily basis.
- There you go.
- There it is, it’s pretty good.
-  It was great.